there's so much happening in this
country right now that boggles the
imagination and you are at the very
center of it and so I wanted to get
started right away you're on the House
Intelligence Committee and you're
investigating the possible Russian
interference and I say possible I think
we all think it's probable interference
with our election this last time this is
this last presidential election and the
big question I have is people seem to
know about this this was something that
you talked about well before the
election why weren't people talking
about this more before November well
this is a great question because you're
absolutely right you might remember late
July President Trump then candidate
Trump in a press conference said hey
Russians if you're listening hack
Hillary Clinton's emails you'll be
richly rewarded he wasn't saying that
out of the blue it was already
recognized at that point that the
Russians have been involved in the
hacking of information the dumping of
documents and I think you know we had a
terrible confluence of events where we
had a presidential candidate rather than
condemning foreign interference who
welcomed it had I'm confident it been
Mitt Romney the nominee at the time or
John McCain they would had the strength
of character to say hey Russians back
off I don't want your help I don't need
your help I despise your intervention
but sadly we had a candidate who
welcomed it and I think we're Democrats
fell down on the job as we fail to
persuade the country why they should
care why does she care more about the
fact that the Russians were the ones who
wanted to the American people to see
these materials they cared more about
what was in the documents than they did
that a foreign power was interfering in
our affairs it seemed strange to me but
yeah as you said when I was growing up
and I know that we're similar ages when
I was growing up we were always taught
in school like it's it's treason you
know that that there was nothing more
sacred or there's no worse crime in the
world than than treason and it seemed
like it was taken almost kind of lightly
that you know Russia might be
interfering but that might be a good
thing or it was adding to the fun of the
combat it seemed people weren't taking
it as seriously as they
should have been taking it well I think
that's right and there's also been a
question that did President Obama he
knew about it but he was reticent maybe
to push it too much because it might
look like he was putting his finger on
the scale is that possible that's
exactly right at the time senator
Feinstein and I were urging the
ministration first to make public
attribution to tell the American people
what was going on that the Russians were
doing this and they were reluctant I
think they didn't want to be seen as
interfering or putting their hand on the
scale they were also worried about the
Russian reaction maybe the Russians
would retaliate my feeling though was
that the failure to speak out the
failure to condemn to attribute the
Russian involvement would only invite
further Russian involvement and I I do
think though when you asked about how
did this happen why was it effective the
president when he did later speak
unfortunately after the election about
this really put his finger on it when he
said that what made the Russia
intervention so powerful so destructive
was the fact that our politics was
deeply divided enough where one party
took the view at least a substantial
number in that party that it's okay if a
foreign power intervenes as long as it
helps us and hurts the other side and
unless we can do something about those
divisions within our country unless we
can forge a consensus that in the next
election because our intelligence
community has concluded the Russians
will do this again that whether it helps
or hurts we will all condemn that kind
of interfering obviously there's a lot
that's the top secret that we're not
allowed to know about but do you have
any concept of when we're going to start
hearing about results of findings or
whether or not there might be
potentially arrests is that something
that might happen in the next year could
it be a lot longer than that this is I
think really probably the most difficult
question for all of us on the committee
which is how long will this take we all
I think feel a real sense of urgency we
know the country is watching we want to
get this done at the same time if we're
not thorough er about it then it won't
add much value and so we we need to move
as expeditiously as possible but I
really can't tell you how long that's
going to take it's an investigation
global and reach and probably one of the
least sexy issues that we're confronting
is we simply don't have the resources
the staffing the size and the scope to
be able to do an investigation quickly
of this magnitude it's one of the
reasons why in addition to what we do
I've been championing an independent
commission because I think having that
single focus well-resourced body would
really add to what we're doing it's
boggles my mind that we wouldn't have
adequate funding to find out whether or
not a foreign power interfere with our
election well yeah I mean that feels
like we are the richest nation in the
world shouldn't we be able to raise that
money and find out once and for all was
our democracy meddled with well you're
absolutely right and the reason why this
I think is so important this is not an
effort to relitigate the election I know
the president likes to simply say oh
they're just sore losers right
we know the Russians will do this again
indeed we know the Russians are doing
this in Europe right now I an and I can
tell you the Russians are very good at
their cyber operations if they want to
get into your computer's Konan and I
think they do they will get into your
computers yeah and yeah and it doesn't
matter how good your cyber defense is
the only way we protect ourselves is if
we can inoculate ourselves if we can
inform our public that this is what they
do this is how they do it and to reject
it that's really only the only defense
what's interesting is I heard a great
analysis not long ago that said that the
Russians have been trying to interfere
with our election in clumsy ways since
the 1980s
they've been very interested in somehow
influencing our election but
pre-internet there wasn't a lot they
could do except make really
funny-looking supermarket handouts you
know that we might believe but now that
there's an Internet what they needed
were two things an Internet and a deeply
divided country and then they're able to
go to work and so it feels like yes it's
going to happen a lot more oh this is
exactly right and in fact in the 1980s I
prosecuted an FBI agent who was spying
for the Soviets he was seduced by an
attractive KGB asset named Svetlana
they're always named Svetlana for
summary that's me in
my case it was fetlock she got my
computer they know everything now well
but you know that was you know back in
the old days a very rudimentary but it
it taught me a lot about Russian
tradecraft and what the Russians were
after how they target people how they
recruit people the different techniques
they used to extort people to compromise
people obviously we're trying to
determine whether any of the techniques
the Russians then the Soviets used then
or the Russians have used now in Europe
and other places they also used here
you